[Music]
hi I'm Lila and I'm Olivia and we're
gonna show you how to make a date night
dinner at home it's good to make sure
that the butter and marshmallows don't
overcook and when you're mixing them all
together to make sure you get the right
ratios if you are from our hometown you
might just dump a bunch of extra butter
in there to make sure everything comes
together but totally up to you I stroll
was sharing because I have to be the one
in charge of everything
so Lila is a great sous chef yeah I do
the cutting the chopping the mixing the
side job we like to make the dessert
ahead of time that way everything is
ready to go what all the hot food is
ready so we're getting the chicken ready
to marinate and we really like to put a
lot of flavor into our food so we add a
bunch of harissa and spices to make it
really flavorful we like to cook mostly
vegetarian but sometimes we'll have meat
on a special date night like this
we love to spend dinner together and
cooking is definitely something we do to
feel relaxed and close to each other
it's a date night activity night
activity it used to be considered work
and especially when we did it on our own
when you go home you cook something it's
a lot of work but now it's like an
excuse to spend time together so it's
like an excuse to have a date every
night that we get to put together so we
made rice krispie treats in the shape of
a perfect heart because that's the most
Valentine's Day you can get at our Lois
we dunk them half in chocolate and then
it sprinkled many many different kinds
of sprinkles over them to make them
extra delicious it turns out that this
is my best art project of the year 20 19
years time for the taters we all them up
real good and then put some salt and
pepper and herbs on them and toss them
all together toss them all together well
we like to make sheet pan dinners
because our kitchen is very small we're
very impatient so we like to just throw
everything on the pan push it all the
one side so we can fit everything on one
pan because we don't want to clean two
pans so we've put it in the oven to cook
about halfway before we add the leeks
the leeks don't get too crispy on top
with this really spicy chicken something
sweet and a little bit tangy is a great
way to cool a day can this yogurt sauce
we're gonna add salt pepper honey
personally smack dill lemon juice lemon
juice now we've been together awhile and
we get to spend time with each other now
cooking it's really nice to put time
into our meals and eat a little better
or about halfway done so we take those
leeks bread those babies on top really
family they're easy you can put them on
anything they crisp really well so
they're good in the oven they're getting
the pan they're not really good raw but
can't get them all so it's really
important to cook down onions with all
the spices to get off the flavors
released at as much flavor as possible
to your soup this is really gonna make
your soup pop we call this our whatever
veg curry soup we eat this curry soup
all the time because you can use
anything you have in the fridge and it's
very delicious
we love adding as many veggies as
possible it's like a combination soup
salad it's super easy it only takes
about a half hour to cook down all the
way or you can feel like we do and just
take it off the stove halfway through
it's still really good leftovers are
great I'm just gonna simmer until those
taters are tender and we like to eat it
right away when we do have date nights
even if it's a night in we always say at
the table so we can look at each other
like human beings have conversation
weekly in front of the TV yeah we like
to spend time with each other so
focusing all that energy I'm making the
table look really nice and setting our
dinner plates and all fat is really
important if you mix everything together
with the yogurt you get all the salty
and sweet and spicy Coolio is a nice
refresher
good